es la escena de una violencia pocas
veces vista en kazajistán unos
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
fuerzas del orden que sacuden al país y
que este miércoles se concentraron en
almaty la ciudad más grande de la nación
a lo largo de la jornada la multitud
llegó a asaltar la alcaldía una
situación que llevó al gobierno a
renunciar y a decretar el estado de
emergencia tanto en esa ciudad como en
la capital astaná además con una
advertencia del presidente
[Aplausos]
los llamados a atacar espacios de las
autoridades civiles o militares son
absolutamente ilegales esto es un crimen
que se persigue con castigo
casaña
tokáyev también anunció que reemplaza al
frente del consejo de seguridad al ex
presidente nursultán nazarbáyev quien
lideró a la nación desde su fundación
hasta 2019 y sigue teniendo una gran
influencia en el país en medio de este
contexto la ong net blogs y agencias de
noticias están denunciando una
interrupción en el servicio de internet
y desde rusia aliado de kazajistán piden
que no haya interferencia extranjera
defendemos una resolución pacífica de
todos los problemas dentro del marco
legal constitucional en lugar de las
protestas en las calles y la violación
de leyes
palabras de moscú que llegan cuando el
kremlin ya tiene un enfrentamiento con
occidente en torno a ucrania otra nación
sobre la que rusia tiene una fuerte
influencia